bonjour lucas je le disais vous êtes à
la manifestation qui est partie du métro
villiers et il y a eu plus âge de gaz
lacrymogène pouvez vous nous en dire
plus oui tout à fait cette manifestation
a évolué on attend tant bien que mal
dans les rues du 9e arrondissement mais
plutôt au but à l'heure il ya eu un
épisode 2 heures
avec lens positive des forces de l'ordre
qui enserraient au plus près cette
manifestation et cette proximité avec
les manifestants entre les manifestants
et les policiers bien ça à déclencher
des tensions il ya eu des coups de
matraque qui a eu aussi des tirs de ce
jeu propose d'écouter la version de
jambes rodriguez s'agit le jeune que
j'ai croisé juste après la première
altercation on arrive même schéma que
tous les samedis c'est à dire que les
flics pratiques l'engagement chose qui a
été interdite par le conseil d'état et
empêche la manifestation d'avancé comme
bon leur semble et créer un climat de
violence et d'énervement et c'est
toujours pareil
c'est la stratégie aujourd'hui du préfet
l'allemand sur paris pour une fois de
plus en plus diaboliser les manifestants
voilà ce qui se passe j'espère que ça va
bien se passer j'ai moi même lancé un
appel au calme à la fois vis-à-vis des
policiers et les manifestants
donc on puisse manifester le plus
tranquillement possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant cela il y avait eu beaucoup de
manifestants est toujours encore
maintenant vent debout contre le passé
ni terre j'ai pu interroger quelques
heures avant le départ de cette
manifestation je vous propose de les
écouter
il faut absolument pas que ce pass
sanitaire parce c'est de la
discrimination pure et simple et dans le
pays qui prétend être celui des droits
de l'homme ce pas normal qu'ils aient
des restrictions pour faire la
différence entre des nous vacciner des
vacanciers c'est complètement
hallucinant le fait d'instaurer un pass
sanitaire enfin passe à yverdon si on
peut dire quoi c'est un passe droit pour
aller un peu partout quoi un sens parce
qu'on voit là les gens veulent une
liberté de plus en plus quand on en est
là on se demande après ce qu'on va être
demain moi je travaille à l'éducation
nationale et moi je suis très inquiète
de ce qu'on va sortir les gamins qui
seront pas vaccinés plus les personnels
à qui on va dire au bout de moi bah vous
allez voir ailleurs parce que vous
n'êtes pas vacciné
moi je suis vacciné mais j'estime que
c'est mon choix et chacun doit avoir le
choix
selon le ministère de l'intérieur il
avait eu 161 arrive manifestants dans
les rues
francoeur mai dernier un chiffre
extrêmement contestée par les
manifestants qui accusent le
gouvernement de chercher à minimiser
l'ampleur à ces manifestations
quoi qu'il en soit à paris un des
cortèges à perdre il s'était terminée
sur les champs
elle est exposée à grand renfort de gaz
lacrymogènes et de tirs de canons à eau
par les forces de l'ordre merci lucas
pour toutes ces précisions